Parents, here is all the evidence you need that TV is bad for kids, especially public TV. When Sean was 14, he loved watching those British TV shows they're always running on PBS-- Masterpiece Theater, Doctor Who.
各位家长，这就是你们所需要的全部证据，证明电视对孩子有害，尤其是公共电视。肖恩14岁时，非常喜欢看PBS电视台一直播放的那些英国电视节目——比如《杰作剧场》和《神秘博士》。
And then there was this show that I would stay up really late and watch, and tape, and watch over and over again the tapes, called Dempsey and Makepeace, which was about an American detective who went to London because he had been, like, setup at home. And he was teamed up with a woman who was this aristocrat named Lady Harriet Makepeace. And I was really on her side.
还有一部节目，我会熬夜看，把它录下来，然后一遍又一遍地回看录像带，叫《登普西与麦克皮斯》。讲的是一名美国侦探，因为在家乡被人陷害而去了伦敦，并与一位名叫哈里特·麦克皮斯夫人的贵族女性搭档。我真的很支持她。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
I thought, you know, she's got it going on.
我想，你知道的，她真有本事。
You looked down on the American.
你瞧不起那个美国人。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
What Sean liked about Lady Harriet Makepeace, and all the other Brits on TV, was their aloofness, how they seemed above it all, how they looked down on Americans. Which Sean did also, convinced there must be something wrong with the nation that produced jocks and bullies, who harassed him in school. And sometimes, joking around with his friends, he would talk with a British accent.
肖恩喜欢哈里特·麦克皮斯夫人，以及电视上所有其他英国人的原因，是他们的冷漠，他们似乎高高在上，看不起美国人。肖恩也一样，他坚信那个制造了在学校欺负他、骚扰他的运动健将和恶霸的国家肯定有什么问题。有时，在和朋友开玩笑时，他会用英国口音说话。
And then it was just something that spiraled out of control. I know that eventually, I was just using an English accent literally from waking to sleeping, morning, noon, and night.
后来，事情就失控了。我知道到最后，我真的是从早到晚、从醒到睡都在用英语口音说话。
Sean spoke with a British accent from the time he was 14 until he was 16. And at some point, his mom thought, you know, maybe I need to do something about this, and took him to see a psychiatrist.
肖恩从14岁到16岁一直用英国口音说话。有一次，他妈妈想，也许我该管管这事，于是带他去看心理医生。
I don't know the different schools of psychology, but he was really very confrontative. And he's like, well, you've got to stop doing this, he said, because you're not British. And my mom just sort of sat over next to me, and she sort of went, yeah, to agree with him, and to sort of help him in showing me this.
我不知道心理学有哪些不同的流派，但他真的非常有对抗性。他说，你得停止这样做，因为你不是英国人。我妈妈就坐在我旁边，她附和着说“是啊”，以此来支持他，并试图帮他向我展示这一点。
Sean was furious. He had an impulse to lecture the guy on how, in fact, he was British. And the only problem with that was that A, he knew very well that he was not. And B, his mom was sitting right there. She was sure to contradict him. He didn't know what to do. His situation seemed impossible.
肖恩气坏了。他有一种冲动，想教训那个家伙，告诉他自己其实就是英国人。唯一的问题是，A，他很清楚自己不是；B，他妈妈就坐在旁边，肯定会反驳他。他不知道该怎么办。他的处境似乎陷入了僵局。
Because that's what I was thinking. Like there has to be a way that I can be British still.
因为当时我就是这么想的。就像是，一定有办法让我能继续当英国人。
There must be a way that this is true somehow.
一定有什么办法能证明这是真的。
Yeah, exactly.
是的，没错。
Well, today on our radio program, stories of people who tell a lie, and they get to the point where they believe the lie more than anybody else does. It feels like it must be true. Happens all the time. And can I say, we are not even going to get into what happens with political figures in this show, kidding themselves about the facts of things. Today we have stories of civilians, people like you and me, basically pulling hoaxes on ourselves.
今天在我们的广播节目中，我们要讲的是那些撒谎的人的故事，他们到了后来，甚至比任何人都更相信自己的谎言。这感觉就像一定是真的。这种情况时有发生。我能说，我们甚至不会在节目里讨论那些政治人物在面对事实时自欺欺人的事。今天我们讲的是平民的故事，像你我这样的人，基本上是在对自己搞恶作剧。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Act One of our program today, The Sun Never Sets-- On The Moosewood Restaurant, in which two young men, both from small towns, try on new identities-- false identities-- and what they have to do to keep the lies going. Act Two, Conning the Con Men. Nancy Updike reports on a federal sting operation, and how it caught con men by setting up a con of its own. Act Three, Oedipus Hex. A little kid tries to get rid of his own father with a very, very unlikely plan. Stay with us.
本期节目第一幕，《日不落——在驼鹿木餐厅》，讲述了两个都来自小镇的年轻人，试图尝试新的身份——虚假身份——以及他们为了维持谎言所做的一切。第二幕，《骗过骗子》。南希·厄普代克报道了一次联邦钓鱼执法行动，以及他们如何通过设下另一个骗局来抓捕骗子。第三幕，《俄狄浦斯咒语》。一个小屁孩试图用一个非常、非常离谱的计划除掉自己的父亲。请继续收听。
Act One, The Sun Never Sets-- On the Moosewood Restaurant. So this is the story of two young people who, for a period in their lives, in their search to figure out who they were, pretended to be people who they were not. We're going to hear from Sean Cole and from Joel Lovell. We're going to start with Sean. Today's show is a rerun. This was recorded years ago. These days, Sean is a producer here at our show.
第一幕，《日不落——在驼鹿木餐厅》。这是两个年轻人的故事，在他们寻找自我的那段人生时期里，他们假装成了并非真正的自己。我们将听到肖恩·科尔和乔尔·洛弗尔的讲述。先从肖恩开始。今天的节目是重播，录制于几年前。如今，肖恩是我们节目的制片人。
Sean grew up in a small town in Massachusetts, a town that was approximately 3,350 miles from London.
肖恩在马萨诸塞州的一个小镇长大，那个小镇距离伦敦大约3350英里。
It was second nature. It was first nature. To this day, I have trouble saying, oh, I faked an accent for two years. I mean, I had an accent for two years. I like--
那是第二天性。那是第一天性。直到今天，我还在为说“哦，我伪装了两年口音”而感到困扰。我是说，我用了两年时间说那种口音。我喜欢……
Sean, could I just get to take a deep breath, and describe for me what you had for lunch today, or perhaps for breakfast this morning, in as close to the accent that you can--
肖恩，我能请你深呼吸一下，然后用你所能达到的最接近那种口音的方式，向我描述一下你今天午餐吃了什么，或者今天早餐吃了什么吗？
As close as I can?
最接近的方式？
--muster? Yeah.
没错，尽量试一试。
OK. I'm going to take a sip of water here. Well, Ira, I had a salad. I had it at the Boston House of Pancakes-- or Pizza, rather.
好吧。我先喝口水。嗯，艾拉，我吃了沙拉。是在波士顿煎饼屋，或者说是披萨屋吃的。
What was the beverage?
喝了什么？
It was a Snapple, just lemon flavored. I don't really like the peach.
是一瓶Snapple，柠檬味的。我不怎么喜欢桃子味的。
Joel Lovell's story began when he left the working class town where he grew up in upstate New York. His parents owned a liquor store in a small town. He was the first member of his family to go to college. And it was an especially big deal, because he got into an Ivy League school, Cornell.
乔尔·洛弗尔的故事始于他离开纽约北部成长的那个工人阶级城镇。他父母在小镇开了一家酒铺。他是家里第一个上大学的人。这事尤其重大，因为他考进了常春藤盟校——康奈尔大学。
It was one of those first days of college. You know, when you spend a lot of time, everybody kind of moves in hordes, and you spend a lot of time in each other's dorm rooms. And there were about oh, I don't know, 10 or 11 of us in this one guy's room. And we were just like sitting around, eating pizza, and talking, and people were talking about where they were from, and what their parents did, and stuff like that.
那是大学头几天。你知道，大家经常聚在一起，成群结队地搬来搬去，待在彼此的宿舍里。那个房间里大概有10到11个人。我们正坐着吃披萨聊天，人们在谈论自己来自哪里，父母是做什么的之类的。
And there was one guy whose dad was a doctor for the Knicks. There was another guy whose father was an elected representative from New York State. And then this other guy, whose father was on the World Court-- literally was a member of the World Court.
其中一个人的父亲是尼克斯队的队医。另一个人是纽约州的民选议员。还有一个人的父亲在国际法院工作——货真价实的是国际法院的成员。
Oh, my.
噢，天哪。
And so it suddenly seemed like this incredibly sort of impressive group to me, and they seemed like just sort of worldly in ways that was just beyond my wildest imagination, and worldly beyond what I am now, frankly. And I remember sort of sitting there at the time thinking, oh, my god. I'm so out of my league here. And then completely unplanned, I suddenly said-- as a slice of pizza was passed to me, this pizza with sausage on top of it, I said, you know, I can't take that because my parents are vegetarians.
突然之间，我觉得这个群体简直令人印象深刻，他们似乎有一种我狂野的想象力都无法企及的世故，坦白说，甚至比现在的我还要世故。我记得当时坐在那里想，天哪，我跟他们比差得太远了。然后，完全没有计划地，当一块香肠披萨递给我时，我脱口而出，你知道吗，我不能吃这个，因为我父母是素食主义者。
And everybody in the room sort of turned and looked at me because it wasn't even as if I said, well, I'm a vegetarian. But I said, you know, my parents are vegetarians. And there's a sort of puzzled look on everybody in the room. And I said, well, and I am, too. I've never eaten meat. And I'm not entirely-- well, I mean, I have some ideas now about why I said that.
房间里的每个人都转过头看着我，因为我甚至不是说“我是个素食主义者”。而是说，“我父母是素食主义者”。房间里的每个人都露出困惑的表情。我说，而且我也是。我从来不吃肉。我并不是完全……嗯，对于我为什么这么说，我现在有一些想法。
But at the time, I had no idea what I was saying. It was like, suddenly I'd become possessed, and I had to think of something to say about myself that seemed interesting. And vegetarianism was the thing that I chose.
但在当时，我根本不知道自己在说什么。就像突然被附体了一样，我必须想出一些关于自己的、看起来很有趣的事情。于是我选择了素食主义。
Now, do you tell people that you were actually from England?
那么，你会告诉人们你实际上来自英国吗？
No, no, never that I was from Britain. But in a way, that I was British. You know, there was a real distinction there for me. Like I'd taken it on, like I was culturally British now.
不，不，绝不是说我来自英国。但在某种程度上，我是英国人。你知道，对我来说这有很大的区别。就像我接受了它，我现在的文化身份就是英国人。
Well, I think what it was is I think I did some sort of calculus that took like a nanosecond in my head. And I thought, you know, I can't actually lie about what my parents do. But I think the connections that I was making were this, that somehow because I was from this town in the sticks, if my folks were vegetarians, then the whole history that that suggested was that they were sort of these kind of leftist, academic radicals who had sort of dropped out of society, and gone back to the land.
嗯，我想当时我是在大脑里用纳秒的时间做了一番计算。我想，关于父母是做什么的，我不能撒谎。但我建立的联系是这样的：因为我来自那个乡下小镇，如果我的父母是素食主义者，那么这背后的历史暗示就是他们是那种脱离社会、回归自然的左派学术激进分子。
And I was living in this bumpkin town in upstate New York. And my folks were living some sort of life that was driven by their political philosophy, rather than, I was just a guy who grew up in upstate New York.
当时我住在这个纽约北部土里土气的小镇。我的父母过的生活是由他们的政治哲学驱动的，而不是像我这样只是一个在纽约北部小镇长大的孩子。
You know, I did the old kid thing of, like, wishing that my real British parents would come and tell me I was adopted, and take me back to London.
你知道，我像小孩一样，幻想着我真正的英国父母会来告诉我，我是被领养的，然后把我带回伦敦。
So I'm sitting there in the room, and all these guys are looking at me. And they're like, dude. What do you eat? And suddenly I realized in that moment how little I knew about vegetarianism. And I kind of tried to be sort of vague about it. You know, we eat salads, and lentils. I remember sort of saying lentils a lot.
所以我坐在那里，所有这些人都在看着我。他们说，老兄，那你吃什么？那一刻我突然意识到我对素食主义了解得太少了。我试着含糊其辞。你知道，我们吃沙拉和扁豆。我记得我老是提到扁豆。
And there was a gap, certainly, in my education, because I would be using words that Americans just don't use. You know, instead of saying drugstore, I would say chemist. Or I would try my best to remember to say bonnet instead of hood, or boot instead of trunk, but I often couldn't.
当然，我的教育中存在一个缺口，因为我会使用美国人根本不用的词。你知道，我不说药店（drugstore），我会说（chemist）。或者我会尽力记得说（bonnet）代替（hood），说（boot）代替（trunk），但我往往记不住。
On the meal plan, I ended up eating a lot of big piles of iceberg lettuce and chickpeas.
在学校的饮食计划里，我最终吃了大量成堆的冰山生菜和鹰嘴豆。
And during that time, would you find yourself sneaking to go to get meat somewhere?
在那段时间里，你会发现自己偷偷去别处吃肉吗？
Yeah, definitely. At first, I would go really far from campus in order to have like a BLT. There's this diner downtown in Ithaca. It felt incredibly illicit. I'd be sitting there, and I'd have some reading material or something with me. And I'd be the lonely guy in my booth. And I would order the BLT, and I would sort of watch it coming from across the room with its toothpick in the top of it, and a side of French fries with the meat gravy on top.
是的，当然。起初，我会跑到离校园很远的地方去吃培根生菜番茄三明治（BLT）。伊萨卡市中心有家小餐馆，去那里感觉非常隐秘。我坐在那儿，带着读物之类的东西。我是那个角落里的孤独食客。我会点BLT，看着它从房间另一头送过来，上面插着牙签，旁边配着浇了肉汁的炸薯条。
And when it landed on the table, it would just seem like this incredibly sort of wonderful moment, you know, when you're doing something just totally unlike what anybody would expect of you.
当它落在桌子上时，这感觉真是一个绝妙的时刻，当你做着完全出乎别人意料的事情时，感觉真好。
I was a nobody. I mean, I was living in an extremely small kind of rural town in the middle of nowhere. It was, I guess, in a way, this was my way of traveling, in a way, and of being somebody, and sort of achieving an identity, which I guess I didn't feel like I had. I didn't feel like I-- I'm just sort of really realizing this now. But I guess I didn't feel as though I had anything that made me up.
我以前是个无名小卒。我是说，我住在一个与世隔绝、偏僻至极的农村小镇。我想，在某种程度上，这就是我的旅行方式，成为某个人，获得一种身份，我想当时我感觉自己没有这些。我觉得我不……我现在才真正意识到这一点。但我想我当时并不觉得自己有什么特质。
I mean, what I realized fairly quickly is that if this is going to be believable, I actually have to-- well, I have to believe in it. But I also began to not only believe, but really sort of take on as my persona, all of the stuff that I imagined was associated with vegetarianism.
我是说，我很快意识到，如果要让这一切可信，我实际上必须——好吧，我必须相信它。但我不仅开始相信，还真的把我想象中与素食主义相关的一切，都当成了我的人设。
Like what?
比如什么？
Well, certain political convictions, and ways of dress.
嗯，某种政治信念和着装方式。
I wore ripped jeans and I wore combat boots, but I also wore like a kind of stage jacket that you would see in a community theater production of Hamlet.
我穿着破洞牛仔裤和军靴，但我也穿着那种你在社区剧院排演的《哈姆雷特》里能看到的舞台夹克。
Yeah. You know, I bought sandals. I very specifically remember going down to this thrift store in downtown Ithaca and buying a pair of fatigue shorts, which just seemed like, you know, I might as well have been Che Guevara at that point.
是的。你知道，我买了凉鞋。我非常清晰地记得我去了伊萨卡市中心的一家旧货店，买了一条迷彩短裤，那感觉就像——在那一刻，我简直成了切·格瓦拉。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
I mean, as far as I was concerned, yeah, I was a dangerous leftist.
我的意思是，就我而言，没错，我是一个危险的左派。
Did you, at any point during this, find yourself in the following argument, where you would say, I've never had a hamburger. And somebody would insist, oh, you must've had meat at some point.
在此期间，你有没有陷入过这样的争论：你说“我从来没吃过汉堡”，而有人坚持说“哦，你肯定在某个时候吃过肉”。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
And then you had to argue your side?
然后你不得不为自己的立场辩护？
Yeah, definitely. It wasn't pretty. And of course, you know, I had grown up-- just to put this in context for a second, if you don't mind.
是的，绝对会。那场面可不怎么好看。当然，你知道，我长大的过程中——为了交代一下背景，如果你不介意的话。
Mhm.
嗯。
Not only had I had hundreds of hamburgers and gone to the McDonald's drive-through hundreds of times, but the counterpoint situation that I always think about when I remember this time is that when I was a senior in high school, my family, for sort of time-saving reasons, decided that a great thing to do would be to go to Arby's Roast Beef. I don't know if you have those out in Chicago. I think they're countrywide.
我不但吃过几百个汉堡，还去麦当劳得来速（drive-through）买过无数次，我总会想起的一件对比强烈的事情是，当我高中三年级时，我家里为了节省时间，决定去阿尔比（Arby's）吃烤牛肉三明治。我不知道芝加哥有没有这家店，我觉得全国都有。
So my dad and I would go to Arby's on, say, like a Thursday afternoon or something, after I got out of school. And we would go in there and we would buy 48 Arby's roast beef sandwiches.
所以我爸爸和我会去，比如周四下午放学后。我们会进去买48个阿尔比烤牛肉三明治。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And they would put them in this cardboard box, and we would bring home this giant box full of those tinfoil-covered Arby's roast beef sandwiches. And we would stuff them in our freezer. We would freeze the Arby's roast beef sandwiches, and then we would have them there.
他们会把它们装进一个纸板箱，我们带着这一大箱锡箔纸包着的烤牛肉三明治回家，塞进冰箱。我们会冷冻起来，想吃的时候就拿出来。
Buns and all?
连面包一起？
Buns and all, yeah. And so we would have them there as ready-made snacks whenever we might want one. I mean, that's the kind of meat-eating that my family was engaged in.
连面包一起，没错。所以我们随时都有现成的零食。我的意思是，那才是我家真正吃肉的样子。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
The other thing was that I had these run-ins with doubting my British identity, like--
另外还有一件事，我曾有过怀疑自己英国身份的时刻，就像——
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
Yeah, as though it were slipping away. And I would really go nuts at that point. And there was one time it happened at home. I was at home and I was like, oh, my god, I have to do something. I have to affirm my devotion. So I think I-- well, I know I opened up the window. And I psyched myself to do it. I was like, oh, man. If I don't do this, it won't come back. And I opened up the window. And then I screamed-- this is the middle of the night, or 10:00 at night.
是的，好像它正在溜走。那时我会变得非常疯狂。有一次在家里发生过，我心想，哦，天哪，我得做点什么。我得重申我的忠诚。我想我——我知道我打开了窗户。我鼓励自己去做。我心想，天哪，如果我不这样做，它就不会回来了。我打开窗户，大喊了一声——当时是半夜，或者晚上10点。
I screamed, I love England, and of course in a British accent, outside the window.
我对着窗外大喊“我爱英国”，当然用的是英国口音。
And then you felt better? You felt like you had reasserted yourself?
然后你感觉好些了吗？你觉得自己重新找回了状态？
I felt like I had done something, at least.
至少我觉得我做了一点什么。
For England.
为了大英帝国。
Yeah. I had fortified my Britishness.
是的。我巩固了我的英国属性。
I would find myself in these conversations where people were saying, you know, you've never had a McDonald's hamburger? What kind of 18-year-old American has never had a hamburger from McDonald's?
我会发现自己陷入这样的对话：人们问，“你知道，你从来没吃过麦当劳汉堡？一个18岁的美国人怎么可能从来没吃过麦当劳的汉堡？”
Quite a legitimate question, I would add.
一个非常合理的问题，我要补充一句。
Absolutely. Absolutely. And I would say, yeah, I've just never had one. They scare me. And I would sort of like talk about the ways-- I would make up these stories about how I'd come close a couple of times, how a friend of mine in high school had bought me a Big Mac, and there I was, sitting on the front seat of his car, and I almost ate it, and then couldn't bring myself to do it.
绝对是。绝对是。我会说，对啊，我只是从来没吃过。它们让我感到害怕。我会编造一些故事，比如我差点吃过几次，我高中有个朋友给我买了巨无霸，我就坐在他车的副驾驶座上，差点就吃了，但最后还是没能说服自己下口。
So yeah, there was all this sort of drama that I lied about. My mom and dad came down to visit for parent's weekend. And they were really proud that I was going there, and really excited to come down. And they came down to visit.
所以，确实，我编造了所有的戏码。父母来参加家长周末。他们真的为我能上那所学校感到骄傲，也非常兴奋地赶来。他们开车从卡米勒斯过来，大约一个半到两个小时。在家长周末前的那一周，每个人都在谈论父母要来，都在预订周六晚上去哪里吃饭，都在计划白天带父母去看橄榄球比赛。
And really proud because you were the first generation to go to college?
突然间，我感到一阵恐慌——我意识到，父母来了，我们去看球赛，我爸爸肯定会去买热狗。球场对面的人如果看到洛弗尔先生在吃热狗，那不就露馅了吗？
Right.
[笑声]
You made it into this Ivy League school. It was a big, big deal.
所以我心想，我必须找个餐厅订位，要么是没别人家父母会去的地方，要么是一家素食餐厅。于是我预订了伊萨卡的驼鹿木餐厅。那里有出版过《驼鹿木》食谱。
Right, exactly. Exactly. And so they drove down from Camillus, which is about between an hour and an hour and a half. They came down. And in that week leading up to parent's weekend, everybody's talking about their parents coming, and everybody's making reservations at restaurants, where to eat on Saturday night. And everybody's sort of planning on taking their parents to the football game on Saturday during the day.
素食食谱。
And it suddenly occurred to me-- this real sort of panic set in that, you know, my parents would come down, and we would go to a football game, and my dad would buy a hot dog. And somebody across the field would see Mr. Lovell eating a hot dog, and then, of course, the cat would be out of the bag.
没错。
[LAUGHTER]
嗯。
And so I thought, you know, I've got to make a reservation at a restaurant, at someplace, either A, where nobody else's parents will be, or at a vegetarian restaurant. And so what I did was make a reservation at the Moosewood Restaurant, which is in Ithaca. And there's the Moosewood cookbooks that are out.
那是伊萨卡一家不错的小型素食餐厅，稍微有点名气。当我们到了那里，我记得坐在驼鹿木的桌边。碗是那种雕花的木碗。我的意思是，这里的一切都让人感觉——嗯，就像一家素食餐厅。
Vegetarian cookbooks.
不仅仅是素食餐厅，简直像是素食餐厅的卡通版。
Exactly. Yeah.
没错。没错。我看着桌对面的父母，他们穿得整整齐齐，很兴奋能来这里。我看得出我爸爸坐在那里翻着菜单，心想，好吧，也许这个扁豆沙拉不错什么的。我看得出他在想，天哪，我刚开了个把小时的车，我只想吃牛排、烤土豆配啤酒。结果我却带他们来了这里。
Mhm.
但他们表现得非常配合。他们非常愿意顺着我，因为出于某种原因，他们以为我真的很想带他们来。我心想，天哪，这些人，我的父母，真的为了我上学付出了太多。经济上，他们一直在吃力支撑，我们背负着各种贷款。你知道，人们为了上大学所做的一切。他们从未抱怨过一次。
And it's this nice little vegetarian restaurant in Ithaca, and a slightly famous place. But then we got there, and I remember sitting down at the table in the Moosewood. And the bowls are these kind of carved wooden bowls. And I mean, everything about it feels like, well, like a vegetarian restaurant.
他们只是想来看看我，为我的成就感到骄傲，而我却把他们藏在了这家素食餐厅里。事后我感到非常内疚。他们一次也没抱怨，就回家了。我可以想象他们在离开伊萨卡后停在哈迪汉堡（Hardee's），一下车就去买了个汉堡吃。但在那之后，我心想，天哪，我必须找个办法坦白这一切。
Not just a vegetarian restaurant, but kind of a cartoon of a vegetarian restaurant.
我的意思是，如果孩子决定在两年的时间里以另一种人格表达自己，这没关系吗？
Exactly. Exactly. And I was looking at my parents across the table, and they were sort of dressed up, and they were excited to be coming down. And I could tell my dad was sitting there and sort of perusing the menu and thinking, well, you know, maybe this lentil salad will be good, or whatever. And I could tell he was sitting there thinking, now, geez. I just drove an hour and a half. All I want is a steak, and a baked potato, and a beer. And there I was, bringing them here.
我觉得……这很有趣。我从未想过我会这么说。但我认为这没什么错。我从未想过我会这么说，因为我现在希望当初没那么做，但我不知道。也许我从中学到了一些东西。我认为这在成长过程中是司空见惯的。
But they were so game about it. They were so sort of willing to go along with it because, for some reason, they thought I really wanted to bring them there. And I just thought, geez, these people, my parents, have really given up a lot for me to come there. I mean financially, they were really stretching themselves, and we were taking out all sorts of loans. You know, all those things that people do in order to go to college. And they never complained once about doing it.
但我认为这可能是我当时生活中所必需的。
And they just wanted to come down and see me there, and feel proud that I was there, and I was sort of hiding them out in this vegetarian restaurant. I felt so bad about it afterwards. And they never once complained, and they went home. And sort of imagine them stopping at a Hardee's just outside of Ithaca, and getting a burger as soon as they say goodbye. But after that, I just thought, geez, I got to find some way to come clean about this.
因为它给了你更多自信。
I mean, is it OK if your child decides to express himself in an alternate personality for a period of two years?
是的。而且这让我跨越了某种障碍。
I think there's-- it's funny. I never thought I would say this. But I think there's nothing wrong with that. I never thought I would say it because I wish that I hadn't done it, now, but I don't know. Maybe I learned something from doing it. I mean, I think that that is par for the course. Now, I think that's part of growing up.
乔尔·洛弗尔和肖恩·科尔。乔尔·洛弗尔是一家名为Pineapple Street Media的播客公司的执行主编。
But I think it was probably necessary for me at that time in my life.
肖恩·科尔在公共广播电台工作。
Because it gave you more confidence.
确实如此。他是我们节目的制作人之一。
Yeah. And there was some bridge that this allowed me to cross.
[音乐 - Noise Addict演唱的《Meat》]
Joel Lovell and Sean Cole. Joel Lovell is the executive editor of a podcast company called Pineapple Street Media.
第二幕，《骗过骗子》。美国法律体系在很大程度上并不坚持“以眼还眼”的原则。如果你偷了别人的车，法官不会反过来偷你的车。如果他们抓到你卖大麻，惩罚不会是让他们卖大麻给你。但如果你是做诈骗生意的，权威部门会通过诈骗你来抓捕你。
Sean Cole works in public radio.
这是一个骗子的故事，他通过在电话里愚弄别人赚了数百万美元，直到他自己成了被愚弄的人。南希·厄普代克报道。
Indeed, he does. He's one of the producers of our program.
那个人的名字叫大卫·戴蒙德。那是他的真名。他是洛杉矶历史上运行时间最长的电话诈骗案中最成功的推销员之一。
[MUSIC - "MEAT" BY NOISE ADDICT]
大卫·戴蒙德是电话推销中心的一名推销员。
Act Two, Conning the Con Men. The American legal system, for the most part, does not uphold the principle of eye for an eye. If you steal somebody's car, the judge does not steal your car in return. If they catch you selling weed, they do not sell weed to you as your punishment. But if you're in the business of running scams, authorities catch you by running a scam on you.
这是戴尔·塞科维奇。他担任联邦贸易委员会（FTC）调查员已经29年了。正是他逮捕了戴蒙德。
This is the story of a con man who made millions by fooling people over the phone, until he was the one who got fooled. Nancy Updike reports.
他住在伍德兰希尔斯山上非常昂贵的房子里。他开着一辆定制的保时捷卡雷拉，是从德国工厂空运过来的。他们生活极其奢华。
The guy's name is David Diamond. That's his actual name. He was one of the most successful salesmen in one of the longest-running telemarketing scams in Los Angeles history.
大卫·戴蒙德只是南加州一大批赚钱赚到手软的人之一，他们的行动基本上是在七年里，以不同的名字一遍又一遍地实施同样的骗局。这是一个投资骗局。把你的钱给我们，我们要投入到这个很棒的900热线业务，或者在线购物网络，或者是这个时髦的新互联网服务商。
David Diamond was a salesman at a boiler room.
不用说，除了经营骗局的人，从来没有人赚到过一分钱，他们敛财4000万美元。由于戴蒙德是该组织最顶尖的推销员之一，他仅在四年时间里就拿到了200万美元的佣金。他能拿到他劝说别人投资金额的30%。这意味着他个人从人们那里骗取了超过600万美元。
This is Dale Sekovich. He's been a Federal Trade Commission investigator for 29 years. He's the one who busted Diamond.
FTC抓获戴蒙德和行动组的其他人员，本质上是通过欺骗这些骗子。他们让志愿者伪装成被骗者，并录下通话录音。由于FTC对戴蒙德所在组织提起了诉讼，其中一些录音现在成了公开记录。我找了戴尔·塞科维奇和我一起听这些录音，聊聊大卫·戴蒙德和抓到他的联邦调查局（FBI）志愿者。
He was living in a very expensive home up in the hills, in Woodland Hills. He drove a custom Porsche Carrera that he had shipped over here by airplane from Germany, from the factory. They lived very high on the hog.
磁带里的那个女人——我不能告诉你她的真名，但她用了“玛吉”这个化名。她扮演了一个叫玛吉的人。玛吉是个真实存在的人，我们执法部门，以及电话营销行业的人，称之为“老骗子”（mooch）。所谓老骗子，是指那种基本会买电话推销员推销的任何东西的人。事实上，她确实在几年时间里，花费了数十万美元——
David Diamond was just one of a whole bunch of guys making money, hand over fist, in an operation in Southern California that was basically running the same scam over and over, under different names, for seven years. It was an investment scheme. Give us your money, and we'll put it into this great 900-number business, or this online shopping network, or this hot new internet service provider.
真实的玛吉。
Needless to say, no one ever made a dime, except the people running the scam, who cleared $40 million. Since Diamond was one of the operation's top salesmen, he made $2 million in commissions in just four years on the job. He got 30% of whatever he talked a person into investing. That means he personally conned people out of more than $6 million.
真实的玛吉在虚假的奖品促销、投资、金币等各种名目上花费了数十万美元。所以FBI找到玛吉说，我们真的认为需要把你的电话号码收走，因为它正被用来毁掉你的生活。一旦玛吉同意，她的电话号码就被安装在了一位FBI志愿者家中。
The FTC caught Diamond and the others in the operation essentially by conning the con men. They had volunteers pose as dupes and record their phone calls. Because the FTC brought a case against the operation Diamond worked in, some of those recordings are now part of the public record. I got Dale Sekovich to listen to the tapes with me, and talk about David Diamond and the FBI volunteer who caught him.
每次那条电话线——玛吉的线路——响起时，那个志愿者就会接起电话，伪装成玛吉。
The woman on the tape-- I can't tell you her real name, but she uses the alias of Marge. She assumed the identity of a person who is named Marge. Marge was a real person who we in law enforcement, and who people in the telemarketing business refer to, as a mooch. A mooch is someone who will essentially buy anything from anybody who calls her on the telephone. And in fact, she did, over a number of years. She spent hundreds of thousands of dollars--
玛吉？
The real Marge.
是的。
The real Marge spent hundreds of thousands of dollars on bogus prize promotions, investments, gold coins, you name it. So the FBI went to Marge and said, we really think that we need to take your telephone number away from you, because it's being used to ruin your life. So once Marge agreed to that, her telephone number was installed in the home of an FBI volunteer.
我是大卫·戴蒙德。你好吗？
Every time that phone line rang-- the Marge line-- that volunteer would pick up that telephone and answer it, and pose as Marge.
我还行。
Marge?
很好。
Yes.
这儿挺暖和的。
It's David Diamond. How are you?
是吗？我给你寄了份录像带和一个包裹。
I'm OK.
是的，我收到了。
Good.
好的。录像带是关于马克·埃里克森的。马克·埃里克森是负责该项目的人，他非常成功，擅长让初创公司成功。你可能听说过《硬拷贝》（Hard Copy）吧？他是《硬拷贝》的原版制作人之一。
It's kind of warm here.
我听说过。
Yeah? I sent you off a video, and a package.
好的。
Yes, I have it.
你听这段的时候在笑。你在笑什么？
OK. The video is with regard to Mark Ericson. Mark Ericson is the person who is heading up the program, and he is very successful in taking upstart companies and making them successful. You've probably heard of Hard Copy? He's an original producer of Hard Copy.
嗯，我在笑，因为我已经很久没听到玛吉的声音了，她听起来那么老、那么脆弱，又那么容易上钩，而事实上，你知道，她是一名犀利的FBI线人。相信我，她看起来没听起来那么老。那是其中一面。另一面是这个所谓的马克·埃里克森的事情。
I have heard of it, yes.
是的。他是真实存在的人吗？
OK.
马克·埃里克森是真实的人。我们的诉讼中提到了他。
You're smiling as you listen to this. What are you smiling about?
他是《硬拷贝》的原版制作人吗？
Well, I'm smiling because it's been a while since I've heard Marge, and she sounds so old, and so fragile, and such an easy mark, when in fact, you know, she's this sharp FBI informant. She doesn't look as old as she sounds, trust me. So that's one aspect of it. The other aspect is this whole Mark Ericson thing.
不。他曾担任过一段时间《硬拷贝》的部门制作人和出镜记者。
Yeah. Is he a real person?
我是说，这种试图将推销内容与合法企业、组织或电视节目联系起来的做法，在你听过的磁带骗局中很典型吗？人们听说过的那种东西？
Mark Ericson is a real person. He was named in our lawsuit.
完全正确。他们想让这……是的，人们可以产生共鸣的东西。
And was he an original producer of Hard Copy?
事情是这样的。你必须投入你所有的财产，或者什么都不做。我会再说一遍。你应该投入你所有的财产。你应该把你所有的投资转到这个项目中，否则就什么也别做。只投入一点点毫无意义。你应该考虑在这个项目中投入100万美元。
No. He was a segment producer and on-the-air reporter for Hard Copy for a brief period of time.
噢。我不知道。那是一大笔钱。
And I mean, is this sort of typical of the cons in the tapes that you've heard, that they'll try to associate what they're selling with a legitimate business, or organization, or television show? Something that people have heard of?
你需要清算你所拥有的一切财产。你要么全心全意地参与这个项目，升级你的投资，要么就别参与。我的建议是，全部投进来。
Exactly. They want to make this-- yeah, something people can relate to.
嗯，我永远不会清算我拥有的一切。
Here's the thing. You have to invest everything you've got, or do nothing at all. And I'll say that again. You should invest everything you have. You should transfer all of your investments into this program, or do nothing. It doesn't make sense to do just a little bit. You should think about doing $1 million in this program.
我的问题是，为什么不呢？
Oh. I don't know. That's a lot of money.
因为像这样的事情总是有赌博成分。
You need to liquidate every nickel you've got. You either want to be in this situation-- you either want to be in this situation wholeheartedly, and upgrade your investments, or you don't. My suggestion to you is just do the whole thing.
像什么样？
Well, I would never liquidate everything I have.
嗯，任何像这样的投资。
My question is, why not?
像这样？那是什么意思？
Because there's always gambles in anything like this.
嗯，任何你投资的项目，总有赌博成分。
Anything like what?
现在我想问你。你曾告诉我你觉得他在磁带里听起来很紧张。而在她说到“像这样的投资”，他反问她“你说的像这样是什么意思”的地方，我在想，你是否感觉到他怀疑她可能知道他在干什么？我是说，他们知道有志愿者在外面试图设套欺骗他们吗？
Well, any investment like this.
不。自从我们上次讨论这盘磁带后，我实际上有了一个关于原因的发现。我在一年左右的时间里，听了超过40盘大卫·戴蒙德的独立磁带——与玛吉的对话，以及与其他人的对话。其中一点是，当你听完所有磁带后，你会发现大卫在那一年较早的时候，要温和、谨慎得多，试图与这些女性建立联系，而且很有耐心。
Like this? What does that mean?
有时甚至会在电话里和她们聊上一个小时——磁带时长一个小时。但这盘磁带是在那一年的最后阶段制作的，很可能在我们的突击搜查前一两周。在那次搜查中，我搜查了大卫·戴蒙德当天的办公桌，我意识到大卫·戴蒙德开始质疑自己是否还想干这行。
Well, anything you invest in, there's always a gamble.
他开始真正担心……
Now I want to ask you. You told me once that you thought he sounded nervous on this tape. And in this part where she's saying, you know, an investment like this, and he's sort of questioning her, well what do you mean like this. I wonder, do you have any sense that he is suspicious that she might know what he's up to? I mean, do they know that volunteers are out there trying to trap them, posing as dupes?
道德上的担忧？
No. Since we talked about this tape last, I actually sort of had a revelation that came to me as to why. I listened to over 40 individual tapes of David Diamond-- conversations with Marge, and conversations with others-- over the course of about a year. And one of the things, when you've listened to all of them, you find that David in the earlier part of that year was much more kind of sweet, and cautious, and trying to bond with these women, and patient.
对他们所做的事情的道德担忧。我相信在最后这两周里，这盘磁带里表现得很明显，他变得有些绝望。他想再捞几笔大的，但他就是搞不懂为什么这个女人迟迟不肯给他开支票。所以他开始变得沮丧，这从他的声音里听得出来。
And sometimes would spend an hour on the phone with them-- the tape would be an hour long. But this tape was made towards the very end of that year period, probably within a week or two of our raid. Having gone in on the raid, and searched David Diamond's desk that day, I came to realize that David Diamond was starting to question whether he wanted to do this anymore.
你看到了什么证据表明他开始对所做的事情产生道德顾虑？
He was starting to really have some concerns about--
大卫成了“重生”基督徒。他的办公室里到处都是宗教小册子，墙上贴着海报。
Moral concerns?
最近才有的。
Moral concerns about what they were doing. And I believe that in these last couple of weeks, and it's kind of shown in this tape, he was becoming a little bit desperate. He wanted to make a couple more big hits, and he just couldn't figure out why this woman wasn't going to write him a check. So he started getting frustrated, and it comes out in his voice.
我不清楚具体时间。我们确实知道，他把赚到的大部分钱都捐给了教会。我们认为这在某种程度上是一种自我强加的忏悔，他可以证明自己所做的事是正当的，因为他在奉献，他在把自己从贫穷受害者那里取走的钱，捐给他的教会。
What evidence did you see that he was starting to have moral qualms about what he was doing?
如果每5000美元能赚3万美元，而你在这个项目中投入5万美元，那就有30万美元的回报。这就是我为什么告诉你，你需要在这个项目中投入100万美元。
David had become a born again. There were religious tracts all over his office, and posters on his wall.
嗯。我不知道。我永远不会在任何项目中投入那么多钱。
Just recently.
作为投资者，你是否有义务为自己赚取尽可能多的钱？
I don't know exactly what the time frame was. We do know that he had given a lot of the money that he had made to his church. And we believe that a lot of that was sort of a self-imposed penance, that he could justify what he was doing because he was giving, he was tithing this money, that he was taking from these poor victims, into his church.
嗯，你知道，到了我这个年纪，这真的不是……怎么说呢？我有足够的钱度过余生。
If $30,000 is what you made on every $5,000, and you put $50,000 in this program, that's $300,000 return. That's why I'm telling you, you need to do $1 million in this program.
我明白。但如果你能以最安全的方式赚到钱，那么赚尽可能多的钱依然符合你的最佳利益，不是吗？
Mhm. I don't know. I would never put that much in any program.
我有义务不去亏掉我已有的财产。
Do you have an obligation to yourself, as an investor, to make the most amount of money possible?
没错，但你有义务让你的钱为你工作——
Well, you know, at my age, it's really not that-- what do I want to say? I have enough to live on for the rest of my life.
对，对。
I understand. But is it still in your best interest to make the most amount of money possible, if you could finally do it as safely as possible?
——否则，意义何在？
It's my obligation not to lose what I have.
当我听到这部分录音时，即使我知道这个女人并没有被骗，事实上是她在骗他、困住他，我也开始感到愤怒，因为我在想，天哪，他真的想拿走这个老妇人所有的钱——所有的。她说，“我有足够的钱生活”。他说，“你有义务赚更多”。
Correct, but it's also your obligation to keep your money working for you--
你是否曾经听到过这样的言论就感到愤怒？即使你知道她某种程度上是在设局，是在开玩笑？
Right, right.
每次听到这些推销话术我都会感到愤怒，因为我就是那个与真正给大卫·戴蒙德寄去数万美元积蓄的人交谈过的人，他们现在连买杂货的钱都没有。我采访过他们。我见过他们啜泣。是的，这让我非常生气。
--because otherwise, what's the point?
他们有什么追索途径吗？
When I heard this part of the tape, even though I knew that this particular woman was not getting conned, that she was, in fact, conning him, and trapping him, I started to get so angry because I was thinking, you know, he is really trying to take all of this old woman's money-- all of it. She's saying, I have enough to live on. He's saying, you have an obligation to make more.
几乎没有。几乎没有。
Do you ever hear things like that and just get angry? Even though you know that she's sort of in on the con, on the joke?
我们有想要上市的公众公司。所以，如果一家公众公司对它做出过评判，那就不是我在说了。如果马克·埃里克森想和你做生意，那就不再是我在说了。你有机会赚一大笔钱。在这个特定的项目中，如果不投入你所拥有的一切，那是说不过去的。所以我说这是紧急投资情况，你应该投入至少50到150个单位，趁现在还有机会。
Every time I hear these pitches, I'm outraged because I am the person that spoke to the people who really did send David Diamond tens of thousands of dollars that consisted of their life savings, and now don't have any money to even buy groceries. I've interviewed them. I've seen them sob. Yeah, it makes me very angry.
嗯。那么你在这个项目中投资了多少？
And what sort of recourse do they have?
我没在这个项目中投资任何钱。我的投资来自于我投入在客户身上的时间。
Slim and none. Slim and none.
是的。
We have public companies that want to take you public. So if you've got a public company that's passed judgment on it, it's not even me talking anymore. If Mark Ericson wants to do business with you, it's not even me talking anymore. You have the ability to make an absolute fortune. And it doesn't make sense not to have every nickel you've got in this particular program. That's why I said it's the emergency investment situation, and you should do at least 50-100, 150 units, while you have the opportunity.
没错。事实是，当他们赚钱时，他们会继续与我投资。
Mhm. Well, how much are you investing in this?
没错。
I'm not investing anything in this. My investment comes in the time that I put with my client.
这就是重点。
Yes.
嗯哼。
Right. And the fact that when they make money, they reinvest with me.
当她问你投资了多少时，你又在笑。我是说，她是在耍他吗？
Right.
当然。她在逗他。我是说，她受过训练，会问他这类问题，好让他做出虚假陈述。
That's the whole point.
但这听起来不像是剧本的一部分。听起来更像是她在刻薄地调戏他，这感觉很微妙。
Uh-huh.
嗯，不。我想我们试图做的，或者她的联络人试图做的，是让他说，“哦，没错。我也参与其中，我妈妈和祖母也参与了，我还在用这个存钱供我孩子的教育”，因为这样我们后来就能证明他根本没这样做。
You were smiling again when she said, you know, how much are you investing? I mean, is she just screwing around with him?
你有没有和玛吉谈过做这种事是什么感觉？我是说，他们会觉得好玩吗？仅仅是想着：我正在扳回一局，在捉弄这家伙。他一无所知。
Of course. She's playing with him. Yeah. I mean, she's trained to ask him those kinds of questions so that he responds with a misrepresentation.
我真希望能回答这个问题。我从未和他们谈过。我也很想知道答案。我也想亲自问这个问题。不过我觉得他们确实能从中获得很多个人满足感。
But that doesn't sound like it's part of the script. That just sounds like her being mean, in sort of a delicious way.
作为一个普通平民，你有多少机会能抓到一个坏人？
Well, no. I think what we were trying to do, or her handler was trying to do, was to get him to say, oh, yeah. I'm in it, and I've got my mother, and my grandmother in it, and I'm putting away money for my child's education with it, because then we could show later that he hadn't.
是的，确实。你知道，我也这么做。我在我处理的案件中，会使用化名去录音。
Did you ever talk to Marge about what it's like to do this? I mean, do they ever sort of have fun? Just thinking, I'm just turning the tables on this guy. He has no idea.
这好玩吗？
I wish I could answer the question. I've never spoken to them. I'd love to get the answer to that, myself. I'd like to ask that question, myself. I think they get a lot of personal satisfaction, though.
我喜欢。我喜欢让这些人说出真相。你知道，这就像演戏。有一种刺激感。
How often do you get a chance to catch a bad guy as just a regular civilian?
诈骗的刺激感、乐趣所在，就是知道自己比被骗的人更有权力。你知道得更多。你知道这是个骗局。让我们面对现实吧，在被骗者和骗子之间做出选择，没人会想当被骗者。但问题是，你对自己骗局的信心越强，你反而越容易成为别人的猎物。
Yeah, exactly. You know, I do it, too. I tape people using an alias in cases that I work.
骗子们总是被其他骗子欺骗。那种总觉得自己掌控全局的傲慢，似乎正是让某人成为极好猎物的原因。
And is it fun?
南希·厄普代克是我们节目的制作人之一。在我们首次播出这一集后的几年里——今天的节目是重播——逮捕大卫·戴蒙德的FTC调查员戴尔·塞科维奇已经去世。接下来，一个孩子试图通过驾驭现存最强大的力量来拯救自己的家庭。一分钟后，节目继续，这里是芝加哥公共广播电台。
I love it. I love to get these people to tell me stuff. You know, it's like acting. There's a rush.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周节目里，我们都会选择一个主题，为你带来各种不同种类的故事。今天的主题是“欺骗自我”，讲述人们自我欺骗的故事。有时这是试图欺骗他人带来的副作用。有时他们只是不知道更好的办法，把希望和信仰寄托在一些完全不真实的事情上。
The rush of a con, the pleasure of it, is knowing that you have more power than the person you're conning. You know more. You know that it's a con. And let's face it, given the choice between being the mark and being the con man, nobody's going to choose to be the mark. But the problem is, the more confidence you have in your own con, the more easily you become a mark yourself.
我们来到了本期节目的第三幕。《俄狄浦斯咒语》。沙洛姆·奥斯兰德讲述了一个他小时候发生的事，那是在那种叫做“叶史瓦”的极端正统犹太教学校里。给听众一个警告：虽然这个故事是关于一个小男孩的，但故事里的父亲对孩子并不好，这可能不是小孩子喜欢听的内容。请自行斟酌。有请沙洛姆。
Con men get taken by other con men all the time. There just seems to be something about the particular arrogance of always being on the knowing side of the con that makes for a really, really good mark.
布雷耶拉比走进我们三年级的教室，挂上长长的黑色外套，摘下巨大的黑色帽子，发给每位学生一本写着《祝福指南》的小册子。他告诉我们，有一周时间为年度斯普林瓦利叶史瓦“祝福赛”做准备。我的心跳加速。这正是妈妈所需要的。祝福赛会让她忘记家里所有的烦恼。
Nancy Updike is one of the producers of our program. In the years since we first broadcast this episode-- today's show is a rerun-- Dale Sekovich, the FTC investigator who busted David Diamond, has died. Coming up, a child tries to fix his own family by harnessing the most powerful force that exists anywhere. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
有一个“塔米德·查查姆”（明智的学生）做儿子，那可是极致追求。她的哥哥是一位受人尊敬的拉比。如果她丈夫做不到，嗯，也许她儿子可以。这本《祝福指南》是一份70页长的清单，涵盖了数百种不同的食物——汤、面包、鱼、甜点。我翻着看，慢慢意识到挑战规模之大。法拉费？鲱鱼？茄子帕尔马干酪？我任重道远。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on the program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Hoaxing Yourself, stories of people who are fooling themselves. Sometimes that is a side effect of trying to fool others. Sometimes they just don't know better, and pin their hopes and beliefs on something that is simply not true at all.
周五下午，叶史瓦会提前关闭，好让我们赶回家帮父母准备安息日（Shabbos）。布雷耶拉比告诉我们，圣贤们说，妥拉说，准备安息日与安息日本身一样重要。我大部分的准备工作就是在家搜寻犹太洁食（kosher）葡萄酒，然后把它们倒进马桶。这是一份没谢礼的工作，我没对任何人说起。
We've arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, Oedipus Hex. Shalom Auslander tells a story which happened to him when he was a boy in one of those ultra Orthodox Jewish religious schools called yeshivas. A warning to listeners that, although this story is about a little boy, in the story, the dad is not so nice to his kids, which might not be a thing that little kids will enjoy hearing at all. So take that under advisement. Here's Shalom.
我父亲因为没喝到他那瓶Manischewitz康科德葡萄汁而产生的沮丧狂怒固然可怕，但比起他喝到酒后的酒后乱性还是要好得多。我会搜查储藏室、车库，搜查父亲的壁橱。但我才八岁，总有一瓶Kedem藏在我没想到的地方。
Rabbi Breyer walked into our third-grade classroom, hung up his long black coat, took off his big black hat, and handed each student a small black booklet entitled, The Guide to Blessings. We had one week, he told us, to prepare for the annual Yeshiva of Spring Valley Blessing Bee. My heart leaped. This was just what my mother needed. The Blessing Bee would make her forget all the troubles of our home.
那天晚上，我父亲因为错过了一瓶红霞多丽酒，醉醺醺地抓着哥哥的衣领，把他从安息日的餐桌旁拖走。他一路拖着他下楼到我们的地下室卧室，砰地关上门。连餐具都跳了起来。“谁要最后一个圆面团？”妈妈问，“我多做了点。”
To have a son who's a talmid chuchum, a wise student, that was the ultimate. Her brother was a respected rabbi. And if her husband couldn't be one, well, maybe her son could be. The Guide to Blessings was a 70-page-long listing of hundreds of different foods-- soups, breads, fish, desserts. I flipped through it, slowly realizing the size of the challenge that lay ahead. Falafel? Herring? Eggplant parmigiana? I had my work cut out for me.
当哥哥回到餐桌时，鼻子在流血。妈妈拿了一罐冷冻橙汁让他敷在脖子后面，据说能止血。布雷耶拉比教导我们，安息日禁止解冻橙汁，因为把食物从固体变成液体被视为烹饪，烹饪被视为工作。就连上帝也在安息日停止工作。
Friday afternoons, the yeshiva closed early so that we could all rush home to help our parents prepare for Shabbos-- the Sabbath. Rabbi Breyer told us that the Sages tell us that the Torah tells us that the preparation for Shabbos is equal to the importance of Shabbos itself. Most of my preparations involved searching the house for kosher wine and pouring it down the toilet. It was a thankless job I admitted to nobody.
安息日禁止39种不同的工作类别。这就是为什么你不能在安息日开灯。电流会导致灯丝发光，被视为燃烧，被视为工作。类别二。
My father's frustrated rage at not having his Manischewitz Concord grape was fearsome, but it was far better than his drunken rage if he did have it. I'd search the pantry. I'd search the garage. I'd search my father's closet. But I was only eight years old, and there was always a bottle of Kedem hiding somewhere I just hadn't thought to check.
父亲回到餐桌，醉醺醺地唱了几首安息日歌曲，胡乱改词，重重地拍打桌子。我蜷缩着，心不在焉地在银水罐产生的冷凝水上画圆圈。父亲打了我的手。“安息日！”他大喊。“书写，类别五。”最终，他踉踉跄跄地回到卧室睡着了，打鼾声很大。我们坐在餐厅里，郁闷地挑着食物。
That night, my father, drunk on a bottle of blush Chablis that got away, grabbed my older brother by his shirt collar and dragged him away from the Shabbos table. He dragged him all the way down the stairs to our bedroom in the basement and slammed the door shut. Even the silverware jumped. Who wants the last matzoh ball, my mother asked? I made extra.
随后的周一早晨，当我们都在读祝福书时，布雷耶拉比教室的门响了，叶史瓦的校长格林鲍姆拉比庄重地走了进来。我们全都起立。两位拉比低声商量了片刻，然后示意我们就座。在长长的黑胡须上理了几下后，格林鲍姆拉比深吸一口气，告诉我们昨晚我们班阿夫鲁米·格鲁恩鲍姆的父亲心脏病发作去世了。有些孩子真是运气不好。
When my brother returned to the table, his nose was bleeding. My mother brought him a can of frozen orange juice to hold against the back of his neck, which was supposed to somehow stop the bleeding. Rabbi Breyer taught us that it is prohibited to defrost orange juice on Shabbos because changing food from solid to liquid is considered cooking, and cooking is considered working. And even God refrained from working on Shabbos.
“受祝福的是唯一的审判者，”布雷耶拉比点头说。“受祝福的是唯一的审判者，”我们都点头回答。我琢磨格鲁恩鲍姆先生到底做了什么才死。是因为拜偶像？还是没戴小圆帽走了四步？无论做了什么，肯定很糟糕。格林鲍姆拉比转身离开时，停了下来。
There are 39 different categories of work that are prohibited on Shabbos. That's also why you're not allowed to switch on lights on Shabbos. The electricity causes the filament to glow, which is considered burning, which is considered working. Category number two.
他严厉地摇动手指，提醒我们圣贤说，妥拉说，在13岁之前，男孩的所有罪孽都归咎于他的父亲。我转头看向阿夫鲁米空着的座位。阿夫鲁米是个胖乎乎的孩子，戴着沉重的牙套，口臭。但我心中对他油然生起一种尊重。我纳闷他做了什么导致了父亲的死。无论是什么，肯定很严重。
My father came back to the table and drunkenly sang a few Shabbos songs, fudging the words and banging heavily on the table with his fist. I sat hunched over, absentmindedly drawing circles on the condensation that had formed on the silver water pitcher. My father slapped my hand. Shabbos, he shouted. Writing, category number five. Eventually, he stumbled off to his bedroom and fell asleep, snoring loudly. We sat in the dining room and picked glumly at our food.
格林鲍姆拉比严厉地皱着眉，建议我们每一个人都祈求上帝（Hashem）宽恕，这样他就不会也杀死我们的父亲。我的心跳加速。“上帝受祝福，”他说。“上帝受祝福，”我们回答。上帝受祝福说得对。突然之间，我有两个方法可以拯救我的家人。我可以为妈妈赢得祝福赛，或者我可以犯下足够多的罪孽，迫使上帝杀掉我的父亲。
The following Monday morning, as we all sat studying from our blessing books, there was a knock on Rabbi Breyer's classroom door, and Rabbi Greenbaum, the yeshiva principal, solemnly entered. We all rose. The two rabbis conferred quietly for a moment before signaling us all to be seated. After a few thoughtful strokes of his long black beard, Rabbi Greenbaum sighed deeply and informed us that the night before, our classmate Avrumi Gruenembaum's father had suffered a heart attack and died. Some kids have all the luck.
勇敢的阿夫鲁米·格鲁恩鲍姆。也许在某个安息日夜晚，他开了灯。也许他在吃肉后喝了奶。也许他触碰了自己。那天晚上，临睡前，我吃了一根鸡腿，配着牛奶冲下，触碰了自己，还反复开关了卧室的灯。“再打破那些灯我就打断你的手，”父亲吼道。这周会很忙。
Blessed is the one true judge, said Rabbi Breyer, nodding his head. Blessed is the one true judge, we all answered, nodding our heads. I wondered what Mr. Gruenembaum might have done to deserve death. Did he bow down to idols? Did he walk four steps without his yarmulke on? Whatever it was, it must have been pretty bad. As Rabbi Greenbaum turned to leave, he paused.
祝福赛的规则和拼字比赛一样。食物有六个基本祝福：Hamotzei（面包祝福），Mezonos（小麦祝福），Hagofen（酒或葡萄汁祝福），Ha-eitz（树木生长食物祝福），Ho-adamah（大地生长食物祝福），以及Shehakol（其他一切食物祝福）。贝果？Hamotzei。燕麦？Mezonos。鱼丸？Shehakol。但那只是简单部分。
And with a stern shake of his finger, reminded us all that the Sages tell us that the Torah tells us that until the age of 13, all of a boy's sins are ascribed to his father. I turned to look at Avrumi's empty chair. Avrumi was a chubby kid with heavy orthodontia and foul breath. But a sudden respect for him grew inside me. I wondered what he might have done to cause his father's death. Whatever it was, it must have been pretty bad.
当开始组合食物时，情况就复杂多了。有些食物比其他食物级别高，与从属食物结合时，高级食物决定祝福。更糟的是，有些祝福本身级别就高，你必须知道先念哪一个。这就是把“人”和“外邦人”分开的地方。
Scowling fiercely, Rabbi Greenbaum advised each and every one of us to pray to Hashem, the Holy One, blessed be he, for forgiveness, so that he wouldn't kill our fathers, too. My heart leaped. Blessed is Hashem, he said. Blessed is Hashem, we answered. Blessed is Hashem was right. All of a sudden, I had two ways I could save my family. I could win the Blessing Bee for my mother, or I could sin so much Hashem would have to kill my father.
意大利面配肉丸？Mezonos（小麦祝福），然后Shehakol（其他祝福）。燕麦片配牛奶？Shehakol（牛奶祝福），然后Mezonos（小麦祝福）。Twix巧克力棒？陷阱题。Twix不是犹太洁食。
Courageous Avrumi Gruenembaum. Maybe one Shabbos night, he had switched on a light. Maybe he drank milk after eating meat. Maybe he touched himself. That night, just before bed, I ate a drumstick, washed it down with some milk, touched myself, and flicked the bedroom light on and off. Break those lights and I'll break your hands, my father shouted. It was going to be a busy week.
我花了一周时间犯错、祝福，再祝福、再犯错，交替赞美上帝和违抗他，尽可能地犯下一个八岁孩子能犯的一切错误。周一早晨，我大吃一顿。一碗水果麦片（Mezonos），一片吐司（Hamotzei），一杯果汁（Shehakol），半个苹果（Ha-eitz），还有我在冰箱底下找到的几根旧薯条（Ho-adamah）。一餐五个祝福。
The Blessing Bee worked the same way as a spelling bee. There are six basic blessings on food-- hamotzei, the blessing for bread; mezonos, the blessing for wheat; hagofen, the blessing for wine or grape juice; ha-eitz, the blessing for things that grow from trees; ho-adamah, the blessing for things that grow from the Earth; and shehakol, the blessing for everything else. Bagel? Hamotzei. Oatmeal? Mezonos. Gefilte fish? Shehakol, the blessing for everything else. But that was the easy part.
周二，我触碰了自己。我还吃了没洗手就直接拿的面包。那天晚上，临睡前，我坐在床边小心翼翼地念了十几遍粗口。父亲愤怒地砰砰敲门。“关灯，”他咆哮。我笑了。我们俩都等着吧，伙计。
Things became much more complicated when you started combining foods. Some foods are superior to other foods, and in combination with subordinate foods, the superior food, gets the blessing. To make matters worse, some blessings are superior to other blessings, and you had to know which blessing to recite first. This is where they separated the men from the goys.
周三，我从妈妈那里偷了5美元，买了包糖果，买的时候根本没念任何祝福—— Charleston Chew，本来就是不清真的，还有Chunky，如果我不是为了要杀父，它本来应该是Shehakol。带葡萄干的Chunky？Shehakol，然后Ha-eitz。周四，我没戴“提齐齐”（tzitzis）。布雷耶拉比注意到我两侧没有挂绳子，抓住我的耳朵把我拉到讲台前。
Spaghetti and meatballs? Mezonos, the wheat blessing, then shehakol, the everything else blessing. Cereal with milk? Shehakol for the milk, then mezonos for the wheat in the cereal. Twix, the chocolate candy with the cookie crunch? Trick question. Twix isn't kosher.
“对以色列的孩子们说话，”他高声引用妥拉，一边狠狠打我的屁股，“告诉他们要在服装的角上制作提齐齐。”那天下午，我在没听妈妈话去倒垃圾、没尊重长辈之后，触碰了自己，默默请求上帝，这次就把罪孽算在布雷耶拉比的账上吧。之后，我通过带入浴室污辱了祈祷书。
I spent the next week sinning and blessing, and blessing and sinning, alternately praising God and then defying him, as much as one eight-year-old possibly could. Monday morning, I stuffed myself. I had a bowl of fruity Pebbles-- mezonos-- a slice of toast-- hamotzei-- a glass of juice-- shehakol-- half an apple-- ha-eitz-- and a couple of old French fries I found at the bottom of the fridge-- ho-adamah. One meal, five blessings.
祝福赛在次日早晨，我几乎没合眼。扁豆汤？Mezonos。土豆馅饼？Ho-adamah。根汁啤酒？它是根？它是啤酒？我辗转反侧，我祝福又咒骂，最后陷入了不安的睡眠。
Tuesday, I touched myself. I also partook of bread without first ceremoniously washing my hands. And that evening, before going to sleep, I sat on the edge of my bed and carefully recited [BLEEP], [BLEEP], and ass a dozen times each. My father banged angrily on my bedroom door. Lights out, he barked. I smiled. For you and me both, pal.
在家里待了一周后，阿夫鲁米·格鲁恩鲍姆正好赶上祝福赛回到学校。我竭力忍住不去问他是怎么做的。“嘘。阿夫鲁米，告诉我。是龙虾吗？你吃了龙虾吗？”布雷耶拉比告诉我们，圣贤说，妥拉说，当亚伯拉罕去世时，上帝安慰了以撒。我们从中得知，安慰丧亲者是一种巨大的善举（mitzvah）。
Wednesday, I stole $5 from my mother, and didn't recite any blessings at all on the bag full of candy that I bought with it-- a Charleston Chew, which is traif to begin with, and a Chunky, which would have been a shehakol if I weren't trying to kill my father. A Chunky with raisins? Shehakol, then ha-eitz. Thursday, I didn't wear tzitzis. Rabbi Breyer noticed that the strings weren't dangling from my sides, and grabbed me by the ear and pulled me to the front of the class.
布雷耶拉比指挥我们排队到阿夫鲁米桌前，握住他的手，念出传统的悼念仪式——愿上帝在锡安的哀悼者中安慰你。才八岁，我不太熟悉上帝的系统，但我意识到，随着我的所有罪孽，我父亲可能也得到了我所有的善举。我不想冒任何险。很快轮到我了。
Speak to the children of Israel, he quoted loudly from the Torah, as he spanked me hard on my bottom, and tell them to make tzitzis on the corners of their garments. That afternoon, after not respecting my elders by taking out the garbage like my mother had told me to, I touched myself and silently begged God to, just this once, credit those sins to Rabbi Breyer's account. Later, I defiled a prayer book by carrying it into the bathroom.
“怎么回事？”我问阿夫鲁米。布雷耶拉比掐了我一下。“噢！”我尖叫。他咕哝道，“白痴。”在最后一个孩子请求上帝在锡安的哀悼者中安慰阿夫鲁米之后，布雷耶拉比重重拍了一下桌子。祝福赛开始了。我们在教室后方排好队，紧张地拉着我们的提齐齐，旋转着发鬓。规则很简单。念出正确的祝福，留在赛场；念错，坐下。
The Blessing Bee was the following morning and I could barely sleep. Lentil soup? Mezonos. Potato knish? Ho-adamah. Root beer? Is it a root? Is it a beer? [BLEEP] [BLEEP] ass bitch. I tossed and turned, I blessed and cursed, and finally, I fell into an uncomfortable sleep.
去年的冠军尤基西尔·扎尔曼·耶胡达·施内克站在我旁边。他冷静地靠在墙上，漫不经心地抠着鼻子。“奥斯兰德，沙洛姆，”布雷耶拉比喊道。我上前。“苹果，”他高喊。“苹果，”我大叫，“Ha-eitz，树木食物祝福。”“正确，”布雷耶拉比说。
After a week at home, Avrumi Gruenembaum conveniently returned to school just in time for the Blessing Bee. It was all I could do to not lean over and ask him how he did it. Psst. Avrumi, tell me. Was it lobster? Did you eat lobster? Rabbi Breyer told us that the Sages tell us that the Torah tells us that when Abraham died, Hashem comforted Isaac. We learned from this that it is a tremendous mitzvah, or good deed, to comfort the bereaved.
祝福赛开头通常很简单。戴维·博根分到了金枪鱼（Shehakol），阿里·马辛斯基分到了无酵饼（Hamotzei），阿维·图赫曼被面团（kugel）困住，他以为是Ho-adamah，但实际上是Mezonos。三个孩子被燕麦片淘汰。罗宋汤配酸奶油又淘汰了两个。第一轮结束时，近三分之一学生回到了座位。
Rabbi Breyer instructed us all to line up at Avrumi's desk, to shake his hand, and recite the traditional mourner's constellation-- may Hashem comfort you among the mourners of Zion. Just eight years old, I wasn't entirely familiar with Hashem's system, but it occurred to me that, along with all my sins, my father might also be getting all my mitzvahs. I wasn't taking any chances. Soon, it was my turn in line.
第二轮。“奥斯兰德，沙洛姆，”布雷耶拉比喊道。我上前。“蘑菇大麦汤，”他高喊。蘑菇大麦汤？该死。我知道我应该多研究汤的那一章。我把一半时间浪费在主菜上了。是蘑菇的Ho-adamah？还是大麦的Mezonos？也许是Shehakol？
How's it going? I said to Avrumi. Rabbi Breyer pinched me. Ow, I screamed. Shmendrick, he grumbled. After the last boy had asked Hashem to comfort Avrumi among the mourners of Zion, Rabbi Breyer smacked his desk loudly. The Blessing Bee began. We lined up at the back of the classroom, nervously pulling on our tzitzis and twirling our peyis. The rules were simple. Name the correct blessing, and remain standing for the next round. Name the wrong blessing, and you take your seat.
“蘑菇大麦汤，”我叫道，“Mezonos。”布雷耶拉比扯着胡子，眼睛眯成愤怒的细缝。“而且，呃，Shehakol？”我加了一句。布雷耶拉比得意地拍打桌子，示意我正确。
Last year's winner, Yukisiel Zalman Yehuda Schneck, stood beside me. He leaned calmly against the wall, mindlessly picking his nose. Auslander, Shalom, called out Rabbi Breyer. I stepped forward. Apple, he shouted. Apple, I called out. Ha-eitz, the blessing for food from trees. Correct, Rabbi Breyer said.
苹果卷淘汰了戴维·博根、约埃尔·列文和什洛莫·波梅兰茨。我朋友莫蒂·格林伯格被奶酪蛋糕困住，我看得出他根本不知道。他明智地给出了两个答案——薄底和厚底，居然留了下来。真不敢相信这只是第二轮。
The Blessing Bee usually started off pretty easy. David Borgen got tuna-- shehakol, the everything else blessing. Ari Mashinsky got matzoh-- hamotzei, the blessing for bread. And Avi Tuchman got stuck with kugel, which he thought was ho-adamah-- food from the Earth-- but was really mezonos, the blessing on wheat. Three other kids got taken out by oatmeal. Borscht with sour cream claimed two others. And by the end of the first round, almost a third of the students were already back in their seats.
阿夫鲁米上前。我朝莫蒂笑了。阿夫鲁米也许杀了他爸爸，但他脑子不好，从没在这类事上表现好过。能进第二轮已是运气。 “贝果，”布雷耶拉比喊道。贝果？我怀疑地看着莫蒂。他在开玩笑吗？贝果？“贝果，”阿夫鲁米喊道，“Hamotzei。”这真是胡扯。“正确，”布雷耶拉比高喊，“很好。”
Round two. Auslander, Shalom, called Rabbi Breyer. I stepped forward. Mushroom barley soup, he shouted. Mushroom barley soup? Mushroom barley soup? Damn. I knew I should have studied the chapter on soups more. I'd wasted half the week on entrees. Was it ho-adamah on the mushrooms, which came from the Earth? Or was it mezonos on the barley? Maybe it was shehakol, the everything else blessing, on the soup.
埃弗拉伊姆·格林布拉特、阿夫鲁米·爱普斯坦和约埃尔·弗兰克尔都被炖菜配大麦和肉淘汰了，切碎的肝脏配面包加生菜和一点橄榄又淘汰了四个，包括莫蒂。还剩三个。尤基西尔、阿夫鲁米和我。
Mushroom barley soup, I called out. Mezonos. Rabbi Breyer tugged on his beard, his eyes narrowing into angry little slits. And, ah, shehakol, I added? Rabbi Breyer triumphantly smacked his desk, signaling that I was correct.
第三轮开始。“奥斯兰德，沙洛姆，”布雷耶拉比喊道。我上前。“冰淇淋，”布雷耶拉比喊道，“蛋卷筒里。”冰淇淋在蛋卷筒里。冰淇淋在蛋卷筒里。我知道冰淇淋，但他为什么要加蛋卷筒？有什么区别吗？蛋卷筒是什么做的？是蛋糕？威化？布雷耶拉比再次高喊，“冰淇淋在蛋卷筒里，冰淇淋是从属于蛋卷筒，还是蛋卷筒从属于冰淇淋？”
Apple strudel took out David Borgen, Yoel Levine, and Shlomo Pomerantz. My friend, Motty Greenberg, got stuck with cheesecake, and I could tell just by the expression on his face that he had absolutely no idea. He wisely offered two answers-- one for thin crust, and one for thick, and somehow managed to stay alive. It was hard to believe this was only round two.
如果是糖筒，也许你真的渴望那个桶。布雷耶拉比再次大喊。我没选择。我大叫：“冰淇淋蛋卷筒，不念祝福！”教室里所有人都转过来看着我。回顾整个情节，布雷耶拉比确实没给我选择。 “不念祝福？”布雷耶拉比问，“为什么？”因为，我紧张地捻着提齐齐解释道，因为房间里有臭味（doody）。
Avrumi stepped forward. I smiled at Motty. Avrumi may have killed his father, but he wasn't very bright, and he never did well at these things. He was lucky to even be in the second round at all. Bagel, shouted Rabbi Breyer. Bagel? I looked at Motty in disbelief. Was he kidding? Bagel? Bagel, called out Avrumi. Hamotzei. This was bull-[BLEEP]. Correct, shouted Rabbi Breyer. Very good.
长久的沉默。莫蒂咯咯笑，其他人跟着笑。布雷耶拉比慢慢站起身，厚实的手掌按在桌子上。这也许是个漏洞，但技术上我是正确的。布雷耶拉比自己告诉过我们，圣贤说，妥拉说，有三种情况绝对禁止念祝福：一是面对超过9岁且生殖器暴露的男性；二是面对超过3岁且生殖器暴露的女性；三是在粪便存在时。坦白说，比起其他两个选项，我想我选择了最不冒犯的答案。对于一个大个子，布雷耶拉比动作挺快。
Ephraim Greenblat, Avrumi Epstein, and Yoel Frankel all got out on cholent with barley and large pieces of meat, while chopped liver on challah with a slice of lettuce and a bit of olive took out four more, including Motty. And then there were three. It was just Yukisiel Zalman Yehuda Schneck, Avrumi Gruenembaum, and me.
“是真的，”我一边说一边看他冲过来，“妥拉说——”他粗暴地抓住我的胳膊，把我拎起来，一路拖向门口，全程用依地语愤怒地大喊。“但有臭味，”我尖叫，“房间里有臭味！等一下，房间里有个裸体女孩！有个裸体女孩！”门砰地在我身后关上。我站在走廊里，揉着淤青的胳膊。我开始哭。祝福赛输了。我不是伟大的拉比。我父亲还没死。
Round three began. Auslander, Shalom, called out Rabbi Breyer. I stepped forward. Ice cream, shouted Rabbi Breyer, in a cone. Ice cream in a cone. Ice cream in a cone. I knew ice cream, but why would he add the cone? Was there something different if it was in a cone? What was an ice cream cone made of, anyway? Was it cake? Was it a wafer? Ice cream in a cone, Rabbi Breyer shouted. Is the ice cream subordinate to the cone, or is it the cone's subordinate to the ice cream?
我踮着脚朝教室门挪去，仔细听。两分钟后，尤基西尔因无酵饼碎配枫糖浆被淘汰。最后胜出的是阿夫鲁米·格鲁恩鲍姆。“苹果，”布雷耶拉比喊道。“苹果，”阿夫鲁米回答，“Ha-eitz。”“Mazel tov（祝贺），”布雷耶拉比喊道，“Mazel tov。”全是胡扯。
If it's a sugar cone, maybe you really desire the cone. Ice cream in a cone, Rabbi Breyer shouted again. I had no choice. Ice cream in a cone, I called out. No blessing. Everyone in the classroom turned to face me. Looking back on the whole episode, Rabbi Breyer had really left me no choice. No blessing? said Rabbi Breyer. Why no blessing? Because, I explained, nervously twirling my tzitzis, because the room smells like doody.
那天晚上，我们要吃传统的周五晚上鱼丸（Shehakol），配一小片胡萝卜（Ho-adamah）。父亲又醉了，唱着安息日歌曲，胡乱改词，重重拍着桌子。妈妈去厨房端出汤。哥哥说不想喝，父亲打了他，把他向后推倒在地，把热鸡汤泼在他脸上。
There was a long silence. Motty giggled, and others followed. Rabbi Breyer slowly rose to his feet, his thick fists pushing themselves into the desktop. It may have been a loophole, but technically speaking, I was correct. Rabbi Breyer himself had told us that our Sages tell us that the Torah tells us that there were three situations in which one is absolutely prohibited from reciting a blessing.
妈妈带哥哥进浴室坐在浴缸边，用冷毛巾敷着他的脸颊。我回到餐厅清理地板上的鸡汤。鸡汤是Shehakol，即便里面煮了蔬菜，因为鸡肉是汤里的主导味道。布雷耶拉比告诉我们，圣贤说，妥拉说，上帝送给埃及人10个灾难，是为了教导我们他给了人们很多忏悔的机会。
One, while facing a male over the age of nine years old whose genitals are showing; two, while facing a female over the age of three years old whose genitals are showing; and three, in the presence of feces. Frankly, given the other two options, I think I chose the least offensive answer. For a big man, Rabbi Breyer moved pretty quickly.
只有在那之后，如果他们继续犯错，他才会用死亡来惩罚他们。我回到楼下卧室，没戴小圆帽走了四步，触碰了自己，反复开关了灯，沉沉睡去。
It's true, I said, as he barreled toward me. The Torah says that-- he grabbed me roughly by my arm, lifting me clear off the ground, and dragged me towards the door, shouting angrily in Yiddish the whole time. But it smells like doody, I yelled. The room smells like doody. Wait, there's a naked girl in the room. There's a naked girl. The door slammed shut behind me. I stood in the hallway and rub my bruised arm. I began to cry. The Blessing Bee was lost. I was not a great rabbi. And my father was still not dead.
沙洛姆·奥斯兰德。他是多本优秀著作的作者。这个故事出现在他的回忆录《包皮的哀歌》中。
I tiptoed toward the classroom door and listened closely. Two minutes later, Yukisiel Zalman Yehuda Schneck fell victim to matzoh brei with maple syrup. And the last man standing was Avrumi Gruenembaum. Apples, called out Rabbi Breyer. Apples, Avrumi answered. Ha-eitz. Mazel tov, called out Rabbi Breyer, mazel tov. Total bull-[BLEEP].
[音乐 - The Fleetwoods演唱的《(He's) The Great Imposter》]
That night, we had the traditional Friday night gefilte fish-- shehakol-- with a little slice of carrot-- ho-adamah. My father was drunk again, singing Shabbos songs, fudging the words and banging heavily on the table with his fist. My mother went into the kitchen and brought out the soup. When my brother said he didn't want any, my father slapped him, pushed him over backward onto the floor, and poured the hot chicken soup onto his face.
本期节目由我和Blue Chevigny制作，Alex Blumberg、Susan Burton和Julie Snyder参与。今天的特约编辑包括Paul Tuft, Jack Hit, Margie Rocken, Elise Spiegel，以及顾问Sarah Vowell。由Jared Ford和Catherine Raimondo进行混音。制作由Anna Martin跟进。技术总监是Matt Tierney。
My mother took my brother into the bathroom and sat with him on the edge of the bathtub, pressing a cold washcloth against his cheeks. I went back to the dining room to get the chicken soup off the floor. Chicken soup is a shehakol, even if it is cooked with vegetables, since chicken is the dominant taste in the soup. Rabbi Breyer told us that the Sages tell us that the Torah tells us that the Holy One, blessed be he, sent the Egyptians 10 plagues in order to teach us that he gives people many chances to repent.
我们的网站是ThisAmericanLife.org，在那里你可以免费收听超过600集节目。本期节目由公共广播交换中心（PRX）分发。
And only then, if they still continue to sin, does he punish them with death. I went downstairs to my bedroom, took four steps without my yarmulke on, touched myself, flicked the lights off and on, and fell asleep.
感谢节目共同创始人Torey Malatia先生，他一点也不嫉妒《美国生活》的工作人员总是能录制采访。
Shalom Auslander. He's the author of many fine books. This story appears in his memoir, Foreskin's Lament.
你知道，我也这么做。我使用化名录制他人。
[MUSIC - "(HE'S) THE GREAT IMPOSTER" BY THE FLEETWOODS]
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带更多《美国生活》的故事回归。
Our program was produced today by me and Blue Chevigny, with Alex Blumberg, Susan Burton, and Julie Snyder. Our contributing editors for today's show, Paul Tuft, Jack Hit, Margie Rocken, Elise Spiegel, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Mixing up today by Jared Ford and Catherine Raimondo. Production up from Anna Martin. Our technical director is Matt Tierney.
今天的节目由我和Blue Chevigny制作，Alex Blumberg、Susan Burton和Julie Snyder参与其中。我们今天的特约编辑是Paul Tuft、Jack Hit、Margie Rocken、Elise Spiegel以及顾问Sarah Vowell。混音工作由Jared Ford和Catherine Raimondo完成。制作协调由Anna Martin负责。我们的技术总监是Matt Tierney。
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can listen to over 600 episodes of our show for absolutely free. This American Life is distributed by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站 ThisAmericanLife.org，您可以在上面免费收听我们节目六百多期的内容。《This American Life》由公共广播交换中心 PRX 发行。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who is not jealous at all of the fact that the This American Life staff gets to tape interviews all the time.
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生，他一点也不嫉妒《美国生活》的员工总是能录制采访。
You know, I do it, too. I tape people, using an alias.
你知道吗，我也会这样做。我用化名给别人录音。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周同一时间，欢迎收听《美国生活》的更多精彩故事。